la jeunesse est une période intense
d'expérimentation une quête de sens si
des milliers de jeunes marqués par les
attentats de 2015 en France ambitionne
d'être les acteurs de la défense de
demain d'autres ont la possibilité de
grandir grâce à l'implication du
ministère des armées pour cette
génération tournée vers l'avenir mettre
un pied dans le monde de la défense
c'est vivre une expérience unique se
confronter à un creusé ou semelle
diversité sociale et diversité
socioculturelle développer les valeurs
de cohésion d'esprit d'équipe tout en
prenant conscience des enjeux de
sécurité nationaux et internationaux qui
nous entourent
des expériences qui devraient permettre
aux jeunes d'être mieux armés pour faire
face au défi de l'avenir les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui cherchent souvent à
trouver un sens à la citoyenneté qu'ils
peuvent porter et aussi trouver donc
dans ce type d'engagement la possibilité
de se sentir utile à la société la
jeunesse française est une ambition si
nous ne faisons pas l'effort d'éduquer
et d'apprendre à notre jeunesse quels
sont les enjeux de défense il faut bien
être convaincu que ce sera difficile
pour les futurs citoyens qu'ils sont de
comprendre en quoi notre pays doit
continuer son effort de défense
dans cette nouvelle émission Le Journal
de la défense vous fera découvrir une
école d'excellence qui s'ouvre à la
différence
un dispositif national ambitieux qui
rassemble la jeunesse dans toute sa
diversité et enfin vous entrerez dans
les coulisses d'un événement qui place
les 18-30 ans au cœur des enjeux
stratégiques européens en développant
leur esprit de défense
trois initiatives très différentes par
la nature et leur ampleur mais qui ont
un seul objectif
bâtir une citoyenneté vivante et
responsable
mon Bono Saint-Martin à quelques
kilomètres de Grenoble
[Musique]
ce décor verdoyant abrite l'école des
pupilles de l'air et ses 730 élèves
[Musique]
un établissement créé en 1941 pour venir
en aide aux familles de l'aéronautique
militaire et civile
il se distingue aujourd'hui par son mode
de recrutement essentiellement basé sur
des critères sociaux et familiaux
la France compte si lycée militaire
répartis entre les trois armées ils
accueillent des élèves dont les parents
qui travaillent au service de l'État
doivent souvent être mobiles dans
l'exercice de leur fonction pour ses
enfants c'est donc la garantie d'une
scolarité stable et de qualité
de la sixième au classement aux grandes
écoles militaires l'école des pupilles
de l'air est un établissement et un
internat d'excellence les cours sont
dispensés par des enseignants détachés
de l'éducation nationale
les résultats au baccalauréat sont
excellents de 95% à 100% de réussite
chaque année
si vous êtes d'accord est-ce que vous
avez tous trouvé ça
c'est que vous êtes forte alors ce que
j'ai symbolisé en bleu ici c'est le
champ magnétique B et en rouge c'est la
circulation du courant le travail
pédagogique très encadré explique ses
résultats est composé
les effectifs réduits aussi chaque
classe compte au maximum 24 élèves une
petite ils ont un encadrement militaire
permanent que l'on retrouve en classe
c'est-à-dire que sont des élèves qui qui
globalement sont assez respectueux des
règles comme tous les les jeunes c'est
ils font toujours contester un petit peu
les règles mais ça reste toujours avec
une bonne atmosphère un bon état
d'esprit et ça c'est vrai que c'est des
valeurs qui sont particulièrement
agréables
un autre élément qu'on peut rajouter sur
le fonctionnement particulier de cette
école ce sont des élèves internes qui se
retrouvent à fonctionner et encadré par
des militaires et donc on développe
l'esprit de camaraderie qui est propre
l'armée et qu'on retrouve en classe où
les élèves sont unis et souvent on
n'hésite pas à s'entraider et à partager
leurs difficultés pour les résoudre
ensemble
on entend un on vit ensemble en fait on
est tous bien en fait et on
dès qu'on a besoin d'aide on se balade
de chambranche pour pour aller pour
aller voir les camarades qui sont un peu
notre famille en fait
et du coup ça c'est ça c'est vraiment
bien ici les cours on est très bien
encadrés par les profs la plupart des
gens disent que ici c'est une très bonne
école et c'est vrai d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que moi je suis né ici c'est
plus tard j'aimerais intégrer une prépa
et puis après une école d'officier
le directeur des pupilles de l'air le
colonel Fontaine a lancé un projet
inédit
accueillir trois jours par semaine 10
élèves présentant des troubles
autistiques
on a besoin c'est qu'on a les mains trop
français une grande première pour un
établissement militaire et une aubaine
pour ses enfants
chaque jour ces cadres permanents de
l'association APF France handicap les
accompagne
à leur disposition
c'est un projet qui est extrêmement
enthousiasmant parce que il permet à ces
10 élèves d'être beaucoup plus proche et
bien des lèvres on va dire plus
classique et donc de progresser au
niveau de leur autonomie et leur niveau
de aussi de leur épanouissement
personnel mais réciproquement c'est
aussi une ouverture pour nos propres
élèves vers la diversité et vers le
mieux vivre ensemble on avait vu que les
contes Valentin et Kenzo sont parmi les
dix jeunes autistes accueillis aux
pupilles de l'air pour stimuler leur
imagination et améliorer leur
concentration ils suivent des exercices
ludiques de vocabulaire et d'anglais
adoré déguster ou sentir adorer ça me
plaît beaucoup parfois ces activités
parce que c'est bien très bien ici
depuis 2008 l'établissement comme tous
les lycées militaires participent au
plan égalité des chances ainsi 15% de
ses effectifs sont des élèves boursiers
de l'éducation nationale comme l'accueil
des enfants autistes à l'école des
pupilles de l'air ces dispositifs
renforcent les opportunités des élèves
concernés mais aussi les expériences de
vie de l'ensemble des élèves et membres
des établissements au-delà de
l'intégration de ces 10 enfants ce
dispositif prendra une nouvelle
dimension dans les prochains mois en
élargissant son domaine d'action
ambition nouvelle du plan égalité des
changes est une ambition pour aller vers
d'autres jeunes vers lequel nous
n'allions pas ou pas assez jusqu'à
maintenant des jeunes qui sont isolés
qui sont isolés dans leur territoire
mais aussi ce sont des jeunes qui sont
isolés par l'handicap par la fracture
sociale par la fracture numérique et
notre ambition est d'élargir le champ
des possibles pour permettre à un plus
grand nombre de jeunes de nous rejoindre
c'est de montrer ainsi à chacun qu'ils
peuvent aussi jouer contrôle dans la
défense en tant qu'acteur civil voire
acteur militaire il est vrai que les
armées représentent plutôt
une image positive toutes les
initiatives qui sont lancées en faveur
des jeunes en faveur de d'une meilleure
intégration des jeunes une meilleure
possibilité d'insertion et de
reconnaissance de l'utilité de la
jeunesse au sein de la société sont à
saluer et sont salutaire
[Musique]
activités culturelles voyages défis
sportifs sortis au ski son fréquemment
organisés le mercredi après-midi et le
week-end
un seuil d'avoir des bons appuis ce qui
parallèle on utilise les bâtons on vient
plier un petit peu les genoux
[Musique]
le sport est un moyen d'expression pour
Kenzo et Valentin
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est piscine avec des
élèves de Première
préparatoire
aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu
particulier on a eu donc deux élèves
donc qui sont autistes qui sont venus
dans une classe à de première et qui ont
effectué un cours de natation et donc
voilà le but ça a été de le refaire un
cours où ils ont suivi à peu près la où
ils sont mélangés au groupe dans un
petit esprit on va dire de cohésion avec
l'ensemble de la classe et donc on a
enchaîné des petits exercices un petit
peu variés dans dans l'activité la
plus-value bah déjà je pense dans un
premier temps le fait qu'il soit là et
qui viennent avec de se mélanger aux
autres ça va être voilà de les
rassembler déjà dans un premier temps et
après ça va être justement qui fasse qui
progresse dans dans l'activité qui voit
un petit peu comment ça se passe qui
soit dans un voilà dans un dans un
esprit de groupe et qui puisse voilà
faire progresser petit à petit avec les
nages d'apprentissage le crawl le dos
voilà dans le domaine un peu plus
spécifique on va dire et voilà qui
prennent du plaisir à tout simplement à
pratiquer
et on a une
pendant ce temps Elisa et Matteo
effectue les derniers réglages avant
d'escalader ce mur géant sous l'oeil
attentif d'un lycéen
j'ai fait de l'escalade de l'escalade
avec Matteo ce que ça m'a plu j'adore
c'est de monter de descendre faire un
nœud de huit c'est facile c'est pas j'ai
plus peur comme je suis une grande j'ai
plus peur je sais faire l'escalade
l'école de l'excellence de la
bienveillance aussi une institution qui
a su évoluer avec son temps pour former
les citoyens de demain à chaque fois les
élèves sont ravis ils ont le sourire et
ça c'est la plus belle victoire la plus
belle victoire pour à la fois pour nous
pour le père mais également pour ses
élèves là qui méritent qu'on soit
attentionné envers eux et qu'on leur
permet effectivement de passer des
moments d'échanges
c'est donc le résultat d'un engagement
fort aussi bien en termes de moyens
techniques et financier mais surtout de
moyens humains et d'engagement personnel
de l'ensemble des cadres qui travaillent
dans cette école
[Musique]
un autre projet ambitieux piloté par le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse a vu le jour par tout en
France c'est le service national
universel
ce projet répond à trois objectifs
renforcer la cohésion nationale
développer une culture de l'engagement
et accompagner ces jeunes vers le marché
de l'emploi
[Musique]
un projet nécessaire pour la secrétaire
d'État auprès de la ministre des Armées
l'ensemble des effets je crois
profondément à ce projet je crois que
notre pays en a besoin
il s'agit d'un grand dessin républicain
pour la France du 21e siècle
c'est un creusé pour le partage des
valeurs de la République
des jeunes de tout le pays de tous les
horizons des bouts de France qui ne se
connaissent plus vont se découvrir
c'est aussi un temps pour qu'il
s'imprègne d'une culture de l'engagement
bénévole et solidaire
le SMU est une chance pour nos armées à
nous aussi de savoir saisir cette
opportunité morbec dans le Nord l'année
dernière 118 jeunes se sont portés
volontaires pour la préfiguration du SLU
dans la région ils ont découvert le
module défense et mémoire nationale
conçues par le ministère des armées qui
participent également à son animation
acte réflexe du combattant jeu de
stratégie cyberdéfense un programme
riche pour ses adolescents âgés de 15 à
16 ans venus de toute la France de
métropole comme de l'outre-mer on a
appris des dates sur la guerre d'Algérie
on a appris la Marseillaise enfin on a
une leçon sur la Marseillaise là c'est
pas mal c'est assez strict mais ça va on
est
on découvre de nouvelles personnes parce
qu'il y a les gens viennent de
différents endroits du coup c'est cool
c'est sympa je te donne une boussole
vous allez travailler à deux ça marche
alors écoutez nous selon un sondage de
lindgp 94% des jeunes volontaires du SNU
pensent que ce dispositif doit être
généralisé et qu'il est utile à la
société
on va continuer les recherches
[Musique]
je connaissais pas je pensais que
c'était difficile en fait non ça c'est
facile après boussole je savais pas m'en
servir j'avais prêté attention et
maintenant chez moi servir c'est pas des
vacances quoi on vient pour apprendre
des choses et
on n'est pas déçu nous avons associé les
joints à nos travaux et de ces
rencontres nous avons rapidement tiré un
double enseignement le premier c'est que
les jeunes souhaitaient être acteurs de
leur citoyenneté et le deuxième
enseignement que nous avons tiré des
rencontres avec des jeunes qui étaient
engagés étaient que ils nous disait il
faut que tout le monde s'engage il ne
faut pas que ce soit obligatoire les
armées se présentent aussi comme pour
certains comme un débouché pour
professionnels comme un tremplin pour
acquérir des compétences non seulement
au sein des armées il menait carrière
mais des compétences plus largement qui
peuvent leur servir dans dans la société
c'est vrai que les armées offrent un
vivier de de
métiers possibles
au travers desquels ils peuvent ils
peuvent se réaliser donc les armées se
montrent attractives en 2019
provenant de 13 comportement ont
participé à la préfiguration du service
national universel
cette année le SMU sera étendu à
l'ensemble du territoire y compris
l'outre-mer et il devrait concerner
autour de 30 000 volontaires
la Grande Ourse c'est la petite ourse ça
devient intéressant alors qu'est-ce
qu'on recherche finalement quand on
essaye de se repérer avec les étoiles on
y retrouve donc l'échelle
on y retrouve le nord pour tous ces
jeunes c'est la possibilité de se
découvrir soi-même et de faire de belles
rencontres
qui vont arriver et je dois jeter le dé
si je fais 1 2 3 ou 4 les deux menaces
vont sur la zone grise 1 la journée
d'aujourd'hui je pense elle a sa voix
elle était bien elle a été cool j'ai
appris des choses que je connaissais pas
sur l'armée de terre l'air ou même la
marine il y a des choses aussi j'ai des
comme les gestes élémentaires SOS les
trois flashs jusqu'à cyber les métiers
de ça j'ai repris des choses que j'avais
un peu oubliées les choses élémentaires
sur l'armée et tout le reste et sinon
après les activités qu'on a fait les
jeux de ça aussi ça ouest c'est cool ça
c'est vrai que les jeunes ne sont en
rien apathique individualiste replié sur
la sphère privée contrairement souvent à
l'image que l'on veut donner de même
beaucoup d'entre eux
s'investissent dans des dans des dans
des causes collectives sont intéressés
parce qu'il se passe dans la société
simplement beaucoup d'entre eux butent
sur
sur les qu'ils ont de s'engager les
possibilités concrètes
à la levée des couleurs
[Applaudissements]
pour la préfiguration du s&u l'émulation
ne se limite pas aux jeunes les
encadrants eux aussi volontaires
viennent de tous horizons on y retrouve
des pompiers enseignants des civils de
toute origine dans certains sont
d'anciens militaires ou servent par
ailleurs comme réservistes dans les
armées
le ministère des armées participe aussi
à la formation de ces encadrants par
exemple en 2019 près de 204 du SMU ont
suivi un stage d'une semaine à l'école
militaire de Saint-Cyr Coëtquidan une
formation qui visait à forger une
culture d'encadrement commune au centre
SNU et a créé la cohésion au sein des
équipes d'encadrement
allez
obstacle à franchir brancardage de
victimes tir à la corde les activités
sont intenses et en groupe
s'ils ne se connaissait pas avant ils en
sont ressortis Unis soudés
là cette semaine ça a créé un peu des
frères tout court entre guillemets frère
et sœur tout quoi en tout cas pour mener
une mission dont on s'est donné
volontaires en tout cas
exactement
pour moi c'est le fait de pouvoir
se format inédit de pouvoir mélanger
trois cultures des armées la culture
l'éducation nationale la culture de
l'éducation populaire et ce ce triangle
inédit qui fait que forcément ça me
donne envie d'y participer et de pouvoir
porter ma pierre à l'édifice en tout cas
par rapport à ce nouveau dispositif
cette formation d'une semaine les a
rassemblés autour d'une vision commune
tirez la jeunesse vers le haut
cet été il continueront à transmettre à
ces jeunes leurs expériences et
connaissances dans la joie et la bonne
humeur
les jeunes ont souvent soif d'apprendre
certains voient loin et cherchent à
découvrir l'univers de la défense à plus
grande échelle celle de l'Europe un
événement inédit s'est tenu mi-janvier à
la porte de la Villette à Paris
rassemblant près de 6500 jeunes
son nom la fabrique défense
les jeunes viennent ici pour échanger
avec l'ensemble des acteurs de la
défense française et européenne
l'armée de terre de l'air et la marine
mais aussi des services de renseignement
des universités des entreprises ou des
acteurs de la recherche stratégique
dans cette immense forum nous avons
rencontré Julien une jeune femme de 16
ans est déjà très active dans la
préfiguration du SNI aux côtés de ses
camarades devenus de toute la France
elle souhaite partager son expérience je
suis allé dans la Creuse pour les deux
semaines de stage on a eu pas mal
d'activités comme rencontrer des
militaires rencontrer des pompiers des
gens de l'armée de terre de la marine de
l'Armée de l'Air ça m'a donné l'envie en
fait d'être militaire pompier tout ce
qui est dans le corps de l'armée
la fabrique défense propose un large
éventail des possibilités d'engagement
au sein de la défense et si Julia semble
déjà bien décidé ce salon lui permet de
découvrir d'autres choix
moi je crois que sont des jeunes
d'horizontaux très divers que nous
voudrions toucher bon il y a un fil
rouge entre tous les jeunes c'est qu'ils
sont quand même des utilisateurs
d'outils numériques il y a des sérieux
game des des jeux en plateau des jeux de
stratégie et puis beaucoup de
technologie qui leur permettront de voir
la richesse
technologique de nos armées et je pense
que tout cela peut être très très
attractif parce que là ils m'ont encore
les munitions
on le sait une multitude
d'interrogations quant à la finalité
autant que la faisabilité de ce projet
extrêmement vaste ce qui est très
intéressant dans le cas de cette
approche chinoise on le constate c'est
qu'elle conférence expérience immersive
renseignement innovation ou encore
environnement les thématiques sont
variées
la main droite sur le sur le manche la
main gauche
sur la manette des gaz et c'est parti
Jonathan à 23 ans cet étudiant en Master
en risque et intelligence économique
s'intéresse de prêt aux questions de
défense sa passion les nouvelles
technologies
en fait juste au dessus sur la tablette
ensuite on a l'algorithme de traitement
qui vient faire une moyennation qui
correspondent à chaque concept et
j'attends ici de voir un peu près tout
le toute la partie technologique de
monde de la défense parce que j'en suis
très intéressé j'ai fait avant des
études en cybersécurité et donc c'est
quelque chose de laquelle je m'attache
donc tout ce qui est drôle les
sous-marins les simulateurs d'avion
tout ce qui est anti drone aussi ça
m'intéresse pas mal j'ai travaillé dans
une entreprise qui travaillait un peu la
danse donc je suis parti
particulièrement attaché à ça et aussi
un échange avec tous les participants
que ce soit des civils ou des militaires
pour avoir un retour d'expérience qui
est très important matériel lié il y a
du personnel il y a de quoi échanger je
trouve ça génial je suis impressionné
des moyens il y a tous les équipements
tout neuf qu'on entend que je vois sur
Instagram ou un c'est magnifique
c'est vraiment
docteur en temps droit public Johanna
une niçoise de 25 ans prépare une thèse
sur l'Europe de la défense
[Applaudissements]
au sujet je suis venu aujourd'hui
premièrement pour rencontrer les
interlocuteurs de la défense donc c'est
un accès privilégié pour discuter avec
différents intervenants dans le domaine
de la défense je suis venu également
pour me renseigner sur les nouvelles
innovations et les nouvelles
technologies de la défense où j'ai pu
discuter avec beaucoup d'intervenants
d'industriels pour pour avoir beaucoup
d'informations sur les nouveaux produits
pour potentiellement les l'armée de
terre ou l'armée de l'air de demain
l'essentiel c'est surtout de permettre
aux jeunes d'avoir accès à plusieurs
interlocuteurs des métiers de la défense
notamment de leur permettre de pouvoir
se renseigner pour éventuellement
envisager des carrières professionnelles
mais c'est aussi pour moi une plus-value
dans le cadre de ma thèse qui traite de
l'Europe de la défense ou justement j'ai
pu m'entretenir avec différents
interlocuteurs qui traitent de ce sujet
et c'est aussi un endroit où il y a
différents métiers avec une
multidisciplinarité assez importante et
c'est la vraie plus-value de cet
événement la fabrique défense est une
opération qui a pour but essentielle de
vous montrer les différents dispositifs
les différentes implications des armées
en France et dans le monde puisque les
armées aussi sont impliquées de plus en
plus dans le cadre national sur des
opérations de sécurité donc je pense que
ces deux journées donnaient une vision
de la diversité finalement des actions
et des domaines d'intervention des
armées donc ça c'était extrêmement
intéressant pour les jeunes qui sont
venus et on sait qu'il y a eu pas mal de
visiteurs je crois qu'il y a de plus en
plus dans les jeunes générations et
peut-être plus largement dans l'ensemble
de l'opinion une nécessité de comprendre
des événements labellisés la fabrique
défense ont aussi été organisés dans 30
villes de France et dans 10 États
européens avec l'aide de partenaires
privés et institutionnel mais aussi
grâce aux réseaux des ambassades
alors à ceux qui pensent que la jeunesse
française est une préoccupation je leur
répondrai assez simplement que la
jeunesse française n'est pas une
préoccupation la jeunesse française
c'est elle qui portera demain nos
drapeaux c'est elle qui te ment portera
nos projets et il importe effectivement
de s'y intéresser pour être sûr que
quand elle sera en responsabilité elle
sera prête et à même de porter
l'ambition de la France les
établissements scolaires militaires le
service national universel ou la
fabrique défense ces trois initiatives
ne reflètent qu'une partie des nombreux
dispositifs à destination des jeunes en
s'engageant avec eux et pour eux le
ministère des armées et ses partenaires
leur transmettent une culture de défense
et contribue à l'éducation civique et
citoyenne de cette nouvelle génération
avec à la clé une belle perspective
s'engager pour son pays